bonjour bienvenue à tous je suis ravi de
vous retrouver dans cette nouvelle
saison d'Europe Hebdo nouvelle
commission nouvelle législatures une
saison riche en événements que j'aurai
le plaisir de décrypter avec vous dans
cette édition je vous emmène en Italie
un pays où la reine zimania a commence à
s'effriter le président du Conseil
italien a lancé un train de réforme aux
pates comment sont-elles accueillis nous
sommes allés sur place mais d'abord
l'actualité à l'heure où les auditions
des commissaires prennent fin les
parties commencent leur tractations pour
les contours de la future Commission au
risque de voir le Parlement européen
décrédibilisé tour d'horizon avec Simon
barbarie
qu'il était bien seul Pierre Moscovici
la semaine dernière devant les euros
députés sa faute être français et
accessoirement l'ancien ministre de
l'économie d'un pays incapable de gérer
ses promesses budgétaires un CV quelque
peu handicapant pour le commissaire
européen désigné aux affaires
économiques car hormis les socialistes
pour la majorité des groupes politiques
du Parlement Pierre Moscovici
commissaire aux Affaires économiques
c'est un peu le braconnier qui veut
devenir garde-chasse avec en plus un
chiffre qui tombe mal le déficit public
de 4,3% prévu dans le budget français
2015 après une épreuve de rattrapage il
est finalement confirmé commissaire mais
l'ancien ministre français a failli se
retrouver otage de la droite européenne
et aurait pu être la cible privilégiée
d'une éventuelle riposte heureusement
que la candidature du conservateur
espagnol Miguel Arias Canete au poste de
commissaire à l’énergie et au climat à
elle aussi était validée il est pourtant
soupçonné d'avoir des intérêts
financiers dans l'industrie pétrolière
ça sent quand même le grand marchandage
au sein de la coalition des députés
conservateur libéraux et socialiste le
Hongrois Thibault nabracite n'a pas eu
le même sort lui cet ancien ministre de
la Justice était le commissaire désigné
à la citoyenneté il devra se contenter
de la culture et de l'éducation c'est
sûr qu'avoir fait partie du gouvernement
de Victor Orban l'un des régimes les
plus liberticides d'Europe c'est en
Afrique et certains seuls la Slovène
Alain cabra tout sec a vu sa candidature
au poste de vice-présidente de la
Commission rejetée alors quel
crédibilité pour le Parlement dans tout
ça
et pour évoquer ces questions c'est
sylvie Goulard que je reçois bonjour
bonjour sylvie Goulard vous êtes député
donc européenne vous êtes membre du
groupe libéral et démocrate et surtout
vous êtes nouvelle coordinatrice de la
commission des affaires économiques
quand vous voyez ces auditions quand
vous voyez les contours de cette future
Commission est-ce que c'est pas un petit
peu la crédibilité du Parlement européen
qui est en jeu quand on voit ses
marchandages alors d'abord je crois
qu'il faut quand même dire pour les
auditeurs que cette procédure n'existe
pas dans les états c'est-à-dire que
quand on fait un gouvernement en France
il y a absolument personne qui contrôle
ce sont les États-Unis qui prennent à
l'extérieur de l'Europe mais dans tous
les États membres de l'Union européenne
quand on nous nomme des ministres on ne
vérifie pas leurs conflits d'intérêts on
vérifie pas leurs compétences donc le
système n'est pas parfait c'est vrai
mais c'est quand même une étape et un
signe supplémentaire de ces espèces
d'exigences que l'Europe s'impose et on
veut aller plus loin que dans les États
membres donc premièrement deuxièmement
il y a en gros deux phases dans ces
auditions la première phase votre
reportage le montrait bien le
commissaire est devant la commission
spécialisée dont il va et là sincèrement
il y a un travail sérieux qui est fait
il y a quelqu'un
durant sa oui pas seulement lui nous
avons eu l'ordre Hill candidat
britannique pour les services financiers
disons que la plupart des députés c'est
de faire le job sérieusement notre
travail c'est de vérifier que cette
personne va pouvoir maîtriser ses
dossiers va pouvoir orienter l'action
européenne et n'a pas des casseroles
sous forme de conflit d'intérêt etc
ensuite on passe à une deuxième phase
qui est là la phase des tractations
entre les groupes politiques ou pour ma
part je partage une certaine nombre de
vos interrogations c'est à dire que
c'est même dommage pour quelqu'un comme
Pierre Moscovici qu'on puisse dire qu'en
fait il doit sa nomination à des
tractations parce qu'il y a un espagnol
qui lui a des intérêts dans les dans le
pétrole pire moi je trouve signé pour
rien donc ça je crois qu'à l'avenir il
faudra autant que possible éviter il
faut que chacun soit jugé sur ses
aptitudes et que si certains tombent
comme ça il était le cas pour Madame
ratoucheg et bien il tombe et le pays
renvoie quelqu'un d'autre ce qu'on
observe malheureusement c'est que si
vous venez d'un petit pays et d'un
partie vous avez beaucoup plus de chance
de tomber que si vous venez d'un grand
parti d'un grand pays alors le problème
de Pierre Moscovici c'est qu'il a été
mise de l'économie d'un pays qui affiche
aujourd'hui 4,3% de son PIB son PIB en
dette donc bien loin les 3%, est-ce
qu'il est pas un petit peu la mauvaise
personne nous avons dû répondre à deux
questions pour chaque commissaire est-ce
que cette personne a le niveau en gros
pour être commissaire européen la
réponse pour faire Moscovici était oui
oui par contre effectivement
l'adéquation entre ce qu'il a fait dans
la vie si j'ose dire avant et ce
portefeuille n'est pas des plus
heureuses monsieur mon coeur a pris un
risque je sais pas très bien pourquoi de
choisir des gens à contre emploi
service financiers alors que la City de
Londres a quand même un rôle
prépondérant dans la finance monsieur
canieté qui a des intérêts dans le
pétrolière pour être à l'environnement
moi je dirais là sur ce coup-là
Jean-Claude Juncker il a manqué de bon
sens moi je veux pouvoir aller voir mes
audits mes électeurs et leur dire
écoutez on a essayé de prendre les gens
et de faire la meilleure équipe possible
si vous voulez placez tous dans cette
situation là ça peut paraître très
subtil à court terme ça oui il va être
obligé d'aller défendre en France le
zèle du converti oui mais ça peut être
aussi vous savez comme le Schtroumpf
dans le cadeau lui explose à la figure
c'est-à-dire que je suis un cœur peut
aussi se retrouver avec une commission
dans certains commissaires manquent de
crédibilité et sincèrement les auditions
ont montré qu'il y avait des doutes en
tout cas sérieux et donc il faut bien
voir si le début d'un processus de
collaboration et quand il est
commissaire reviendront quand Pierre
Moscovici reviendra peut-être avec une
décision très lourde de conséquences
pour la France est-ce qu'il sera
considéré comme ayant été impartial ou
est-ce qu'il y aura un espèce de soupçon
qui est peut-être pas justifié il a
essayé de s'en défendre et peut-être
mais on pourra pas empêcher les gens
d'avoir ce soupçon et ça c'est dommage
alors justement à ce propos je voudrais
qu'on réécoute quelqu'un qui fait partie
de l'association Havas qui est un petit
peu pointé la problématique de Monsieur
cagnété on l'écoute
les intérêts personnels et financiers de
Monsieur cagnier et de sa famille dans
l'industrie du pétrole et son action en
faveur des explorations pétrolières en
Espagne en tant que ministre de
l'environnement font de lui une personne
totalement inadaptée pour ce poste
vous êtes d'accord totalement inadapté
sincèrement c'est pas ma commission je
n'ai pas d'éléments sur ce que fait
monsieur cagnété comme affaire
honnêtement je veux jamais que personne
à partir du moment où vous avez des
conflits d'intérêts et là en
l'occurrence ils sont avérés il a même
du changer sa déclaration d'intérêt
personnel oui ça me choque sincèrement
ça me choque que le PPE donc le Parti
populaire européen les soutenu en verre
et contre tout je crois que ce qu'on
doit aux citoyens européens c'est d'être
extrêmement réglo sur l'honnêteté j'ai
tendance quand même à rappeler qu'en
France on a eu récemment un gouvernement
dans lequel on a eu un ministre qui
payait pas ses impôts et que le
Parlement français ne s'en n'était pas
aperçu donc effectivement il faut
améliorer les choses il faut contrôler
les situations de conflit d'intérêt au
niveau national et au niveau européen là
on a l'impression qu'il y a plus de
magouilles au niveau européen mais
pourquoi parce qu'on a un système qu'il
est révèle en gros c'est un petit peu le
contrepoid de la transparence on serait
tellement transparent que on pourrait se
permettre aujourd'hui d'avoir des
commissaires qui déclarent qu'ils ont
des conflits d'intérêt mais c'est pas
grave on va faire avec personnellement
et d'ailleurs ça pèsera dans mon vote je
regarderai un peu quel est l'équilibre
général évidemment comme ils sont 28 en
tout c'est toujours difficile de se
priver aussi de gens de grande qualité
qui eux ne sont pas dans des conflits
d'intérêts parce qu'il y en a un qui
pose un problème et là encore la
responsabilité et de Jean-Claude Juncker
et des parties qui l'ont soutenu pour ma
part si j'avais eu à voter sur lui dans
cette commission là vous avez pas
apporter mon soutien alors justement le
22 octobre vous serez amené à voter
l'ensemble de la commission ou alors à
la rejeter quel sera votre position
sylvie Goulard goûter pour l'instant je
n'en sais rien vraiment je n'en sais
rien pourquoi parce que d'abord il
manque une des pièces du puzzle
deuxièmement parce qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de seinformer mutuellement sur
les profils de chacun ce qui a pu
apparaître en cours de route est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres cas dans lesquels il
y a eu des doutes qui ont été couverts
je prendrai ma décision avec les autres
membres de mon groupe encore une fois
c'est une décision lourde de
conséquences de rejeter en bloc toute
une commission à un moment où on a
besoin de se mettre au travail
d'apporter de la croissance et des
emplois aux Européens c'est très dommage
que ce genre de tractation en tâche un
processus dont je crois par ailleurs
qu'il est positif mais donc ça voudrait
dire que parce qu'il y a urgence de
mettre en place des politiques de
réforme structurelle de plan de relance
comme le veut Jean-Claude Juncker il
faudrait quand même accepter une
commission même si elle n'est pas
parfaite écoutez c'est un conflit de
devoir classique dans la vie politique
on en a toujours on n'a jamais le choix
jamais entre ce qui est bien et ce qui
est mal on a en général le choix entre
deux solutions qui ont de sérieuses
inconvénients et un certain nombre
d'avantages nous réfléchirons de tout ça
dans le groupe et puis je vous le
redirai le vers le 22 donc vous n'avez
aucune information quant à la future
position du groupe libéraux démocrate là
dessus non nous nous avons posé deux
trois conditions d'abord le sort de
madame ratouchet qui en plus était
libéral deuxièmement nous avons soulevé
un lièvre si j'ose dire en commission
économique et monétaire qui nous
préoccupe énormément et c'est peut-être
pour cette raison là qu'éventuellement
de toute façon on dirait non c'est que
on a partagé le portefeuille économique
en 3 vous avez Pierre Moscovici vous
avez l'ancien Premier ministre laiton
qui s'appelle monsieur Dombrowski si
vous avez l'ancien Premier ministre
finlandais qui s'appelle monsieur
catinet depuis le début de la procédure
nous parlementaire avant demandé à
Monsieur Juncker de nous dire qui fait
quoi c'est pas compliqué on veut savoir
qui voulait
ce que nous subdons c'est que il en a
mis deux pour se contrôler mutuellement
d'ailleurs il y a une fuite d'un
document dans le variante qui a fait
apparaître dans un journal anglais qui a
fait apparaître qu'effectivement
monsieur dombrose qui c'est Monsieur
Moscovici qui sont de deux bords
politiques opposés devenait finalement
devront décider ensemble ce qui est une
sorte d'attelage un peu bizarre moi je
préfère très sincèrement une personne
qui n'est pas de mon bord politique du
tout et qui assume les décisions qu'il
prend d'autant plus qu'il les prend avec
l'ensemble du collège des commissaires
plutôt que cette espèce de système de
suspicion organisée qui peut aboutir à
ce que d'abord sur la cacophonie à
l'extérieur et deuxièmement ce soit
Jean-Claude Juncker à la tête avec son
directeur de cabinet qui décide par
exemple et dans ce cas là on nous
vendrait une politisation qui aboutirait
à donner plus de pouvoir au
fonctionnaires qu'avant bon bah écoutez
on suivra ça le 22 merci sylvie Goulard
d'avoir été avec nous nous on continue
direction l'Italie depuis son accession
au poste de Premier ministre italien
Matteo Renzi fascine notamment ses
confrères français à l'heure où celui-ci
vient d'obtenir une réforme du Code du
travail ou du moins un vote de confiance
du Sénat italien pour cette réforme nous
avons voulu savoir comment celui-ci
opérait pour mettre en place ces
réformes structurelles direction Rome
avec Yaël goujon
à Rome l'été n'est pas encore fini mais
la rentrée politique elle est bien
entamée depuis son arrivée au pouvoir
Renzi bouleverse la péninsule l'une de
ses réformes phares c'est celle du Sénat
les fêtes
que je n'ai pas l'âge pour siéger au
Sénat et que je serai le dernier
président du conseil à vous demander le
vote de confiance
le projet de Renzi que la chambre haute
comporte sans sénateur contre 315
aujourd'hui ils ne seront plus rémunérés
ce qui représenterait une économie de
500 millions d'euros pour l'État après
de longues années à la rail le
journaliste vedette Minéo est devenu
sénateur l'année dernière
se suicide en transformant une assemblée
donnant de grandes orientations même
avec des compétences politiques limitées
pour n'en faire qu'une assemblée de
conseillers locaux
en faisant ça on détruit un pont de la
Constitution et on produit un système
autoritaire
comme une cinquantaine de parlementaires
du parti démocrate de Renzi le nouveau
sénateur fait partie des frondeurs de
l'aile gauche
chaque interview est l'occasion de
constater cette affrontement notamment
sur la réforme du travail
en fait le marché du travail est devenu
fou avec un nombre hallucinant de
précaire au moment même où les riches
continuent de s'enrichir et les mafia de
s'engraisser parce que nous avons eu 20
ans de libéralisme et de mirage
berlusconien appuyé par une gauche
soumise qui abandonnait toute lutte
sociale pour une idée on gagnera les
élections et ensuite on gouvernera
la ministre Mahdia en charge de la
simplification de la fonction publique
vient 2 à 3 fois par semaine au Sénat
pour défendre ses réformes
l'occasion aussi pour les journalistes
de savoir où en sont les économies
prenaient pour les ministères
on a les voitures de
de fonds oui oui le décret d'application
est imminent et désormais on ira tous à
pied aux réunions
la première action du gouvernement était
celle de augmenter les salaires de qui
gagne peu d'argent avec 80 euros en plus
chaque mois pour ceux qui gagnent moins
de
26000 euros par an parce que l'idée
c'est pour faire repartir la croissance
il faut aussi aider les personnes à
avoir plus d'argent pour consommer un
peu plus
j'ai relancé rigueur politique de
l'offre et de la demande BC en même
temps la fiscalité et les dépenses
publiques une logique économique qui
séduit aussi les entrepreneurs
les PME constituent l'essentiel du tissu
industriel italien
en banlieue de Rome Virginie opalini
dirige une entreprise d'une centaine de
salariés fondés il y a 140 ans par son
arrière-grand-père
a besoin de ces réformes dont on parle
depuis 20 ans
les entreprises sont trop taxées en
Italie et du coup elle n'investissent
pas
salarié qui travaille mal pour le
remplacer par un meilleur actuellement
la procédure est extrêmement longue
mais tous les Italiens ne s'enthousiasme
pas autant pour celui qu'on surnomme le
démolisseur
et il ne pratique pas les bougabunga
mais sa politique est identique il se
dit de gauche mais son action le
contredit il va supprimer un morceau du
droit du travail ce que Berlusconi n'a
pas réussi à faire en 20 ans alors si
c'est ça une politique de gauche
malgré les réformes le taux de chômage
continue de stagner et l'embellie tarde
à venir du coup la grande s'organise
une signature pour le référendum contre
le pacte budgétaire européen
Fiori le collectif Stop l'austérité
recueille les signatures nécessaires
pour organiser un référendum
d'initiative populaire comme la loi
italienne l'autorise
l'austérité en elle-même ne fonctionne
pas il y a des recettes économiques
assez simples qu'on pourrait appliquer
mais ça c'est au gouvernement actuel de
le faire
serait aussi un signal politique qui
démontrerait qu'une majorité d'Italiens
veulent arrêter l'austérité et d'une
certaine manière le gouvernement Renzi
serait renforcé dans son action en
Europe
la règle d'or budgétaire ici comme
ailleurs en Europe et pointe du doigt ce
référendum permettrait à l'Italie de
s'extirper de ce carcan car à l'heure au
Renzi promet près de 100 milliards
d'euros pour relancer l'économie ces
marges de manœuvre sont réduites
alors quelle marge de manœuvre
budgétaire pour Matteo Renzi et l'Italie
nous recevons aujourd'hui David Careta
journaliste italien à la radio radicale
pour en parler bonjour et Giulia sandrie
politologue à l'Université Catholique de
Lille bonjour
quand vous voyez ça Giulia est-ce que
vous vous dites que Mateo Renzi en fait
et quelqu'un qui est une forme de
Berlusconi de gauche si toutefois on
peut le dire ainsi ou un réformateur
visionnaire ou alors juste un très bon
communicant c'est clair que l'aspect
principal de la personnalité politique
des reinsi c'est sa capacité à
révolutionner le message par rapport à
ses prédicaceurs à la tête du parti
démocrate c'est lui que à l'intérieur du
parti avant et au gouvernement après
addict les rythmes de la communication
du parti ou du gouvernement et qui a
dicté aussi les thèmes plus chauds à
l'agenda du gouvernement et avant du
parti donc vous êtes d'accord David
carreta en gros c'est juste un très bon
communicants mais on attend encore pour
la capacité à réformer c'est les trois
choses ensemble c'est un réformateur
mais d'ailleurs même de l'usconi c'était
présenté comme un grand
réformateurs
les prochains mois et année parce que
pour l'instant on a beaucoup d'annonces
quelques reformes qui ont passé à la
chambre mais pas encore au Sénat ou au
Sénat et pas la chambre
on a les 80 euros mais c'est une mesure
très populiste
en termes concrets ils ont pas apporté
de la croissance à l'Italie on a besoin
de réformes sur le côté de l'offre pas
de la demande en ce moment et on va voir
s'il va avoir succès ou comme Berlusconi
va être un petit peu manger par le
système conservateur italien
justement Julia là on voit bien que sur
la question de la réforme du Sénat il y
a une forme de blocage de la part d'une
part d'ailleurs de son camp est-ce que
le Parti démocrate n'est pas n'est pas
en passe en fait d'exploser face à cette
espèce de de réformateur visionnaire
mais qui à la fois un peu berlusconnaise
qui est qu'on a du mal à cataloguer
c'est difficile de faire des prévisions
mais d'autre part le Parti démocrate par
rapport à d'autres parties en Italie
c'est un des rares qui a une
réglementation très claire des factions
et des courants internes donc on peut
parler plutôt d'un parti qui est animé
par une démocratie interne c'est normal
d'avoir des factions c'est normal
d'avoir des coins différents il est
clair que le nombre de frondeurs
augmente à chaque vote de confiance au
Sénat ou à la Chambre lors de ce dernier
de vote de hier il y a eu 27 sénateurs
qui est sur la réforme du Code du
travail qui ont déclaré de n'êtes pas
d'accord et une partie voter contre donc
contre son propre gouvernement justement
David sur la réforme du Code du travail
donc c'est l'article 18 qui va permettre
semble-t-il de licencie licencier plus
facilement des ouvriers ou des salariés
en CDI aussi peut-être effectivement
est-ce qu'il y a une véritable capacité
de réformer l'Italie aussi profondément
sachant que la personne qu'on a vu dans
ce reportage nous le disait bien même
Berlusconi n'y est pas arrivé
en Italie en
1999 il y a eu un référendum justement
sur le fameux article 18
tout le monde était opposé la droite la
gauche le syndicats etc et aujourd'hui
on discute un corps de ça
je sais pas s'il va y arriver ça va être
très difficile parce que les syndicats
sont contre une partie de la gauche
en cas de réforme le fait que cet
article 18
en ce moment c'est un obstacle à
l'embauche et a créé un marché du
travail à deux niveaux d'un côté on a
les gens qui ont un contrat à temps
indéterminé pour toujours
de l'autre côté on a les jeunes qui ont
aucune garantie il faut essayer de
changer tout ça et c'est ce que rien ne
tirait en train de essayer de faire au
moins il dit qu'il qu'il voudrait le
faire
est-ce que vous on peut dire que c'est
juste en référence ce code du travail
qu'on va pouvoir trouver une solution au
chômage des jeunes
il faut se rappeler qu'entre 2007 et
2014 le chemin des moins de 25 ans après
ce que doublé et passer de 3 à 44 %.
donc c'est clair 18 c'est ça c'est clair
que ça va dans la bonne direction mais
il y a toute une tri d'autres réformes
qui doivent être faites
très très large on peut parler des
réformes du coup du travail donc tout ce
qui est côté fiscalité des règles pour
la création de nouvelles entreprises des
règles de passation de marché donc ça
c'est dans un pas dans la bonne
direction mais c'est clair que c'est pas
suffisant alors justement sur cette
question de la réforme du marché du
travail nous avions rencontré à l'époque
de notre reportage un jeune chômeur qui
était devant le Pôle Emploi italien je
voudrais qu'on écoute
moi l'Italie je voudrais en partir si
possible le système fonctionne mieux à
l'étranger dit-on même si parfois les
gens exagèrent
mais au moins à l'étranger les lois sont
respectées ici en Italie on fait des
lois qui ne sont jamais respectées
des services publics ne fonctionnent pas
rien ne fonctionne l'Italie pourrait
être une vraie petite Suisse mais ces
politiciens l'ont complètement détruite
David l'Italie une future petite Suisse
si toutefois les hommes politiques
italien se décident à la mettre en
oeuvre politique italiens sont les mêmes
depuis 20 ans
politique qui est là depuis 20 ans
je crois quelque chose comme ça mais en
tout cas c'est vrai ce que ce jeune qui
était pas très jeune en fait une petite
35 il était à la recherche d'un emploi
depuis déjà très longtemps
qui comme au début du siècle sont en
train de partir à l'étranger et si vous
faites un tour par pour Bruxelles dans
Bruxelles vous allez découvrir
vraiment des centaines d'Italiens qui
travaillent dans des petits magasins
dans des restaurants des gens aussi de
succès qui ont ouvert au début une
petite pizzeria et ben non ils n'ont
trois dans la ville 4 etc mais est-ce
que c'est pas un constat d'échec de dire
que le seul salut de la jeunesse
italienne aujourd'hui c'est d'aller à
l'étranger Julien
c'est clair que le dernier rapport de
sur l'immigration et l'immigration
italienne qui a été publiée justement
hier montrent que pour la première année
du puits de décennies le nombre de
jeunes sortants est plus grand du nombre
des migrants qui arrivent en Italie
c'est clair qu'il y a un problème par
rapport à un particulier aux jeunes qui
sont très qualifiés qui préfèrent qui
trouve plus d'occasions plus de
possibilités de travail ailleurs plutôt
qu'en Italie justement c'était un petit
peu l'objet de la réunion qui s'est tenu
à Milan entre Angela Merkel François
Hollande et Matteo Renzi sur la question
de l'emploi notamment de l'emploi des
jeunes qu'est-ce qui a été annoncé
durant cette réunion qu'est-ce qui a été
en gros nouveau par rapport à ce qu'on
savait déjà sur la garantie jeunesse et
le travail qu'on doit faire sur l'emploi
des jeunes il faut faire plus mais on
sait pas très bien quoi faire de plus il
y a pas d'argent dans le budget européen
non il a été abaissé pour la première
fois de son histoire voilà on a on a
prévu 6 milliards pendant deux ans pour
la garantie jeune qui a appliquait
différemment dans dans les pays
européens donc avec des effets
différents
c'est un problème structurel on va pas
le résoudre avec des annonces comme on a
fait à Milan de la volonté politique
à la fin c'est les entreprises qui
embauchent c'est pas le politicien donc
en gros tant qu'on n'aura pas réformé
effectivement ce code du travail et
flexibiliser un petit peu
justement est-ce que c'est aussi le
problème de la France on voit que tous
les socialistes français François
Hollande Manuel Valls ont tendance à
venir en Italie se faire photographier
il y a une forme de Renzi Mania en ce
moment notamment chez les socialistes
français est-ce qu'on est dans la même
configuration en Italie et en France
aujourd'hui sur ces questions de réforme
structurelles mais les deux systèmes
économiques sont complément des Francs
et surtout les deux systèmes politiques
le système politique italien
ce se base sur par exemple avant la
réforme du Sénat sur une situation de
Bic amerline parfait où les deux
chambres avaient les mêmes pouvoirs et
donc c'est clair que la procédure
législative était beaucoup plus
farraginale que que en France chose pour
laquelle la réforme de 26 semble aller
dans le bon dans le bon sens il est
clair que tout le monde veut bénéficier
du période de l'une des miel qui est
encore un cours en Italie pour le
gouvernement Annecy le gouverneur en
France pour manuel
vallsi est au pouvoir depuis un peu plus
de 7 mois c'est clair qu'il y en a
encore dans la phase où tout semble bien
tout semble aller dans la bonne
direction même si il y a les premières
critiques qui commencent à se produire
des critiques à ces pointus il y a le
principal un des principales journées
italien le collier de la Sierra qui a
quelques jours à publier un édito très
très dur sur la politique des annonces
du gouvernement et donc c'est clair que
maintenant le gouvernement doit
commencer à montrer des résultats et
rapidement sinon le risque c'est quoi
c'est que l'Italie devienne une forme de
France mais de la péninsule c'est David
Carter puisque vous connaissez bien
aussi l'environnement français est-ce
que vous verriez ma théorie de venir une
forme de François Hollande en quelque
temps je sais pas parce que l'opinion
publique italienne est assez différente
par rapport à celle françaises moins
révolutionnaire je dirais mais toujours
à la recherche d'un homme fort
un petit peu populiste etc par rapport à
la à la France l'Italie a des faiblesses
et là aussi de points forts il y a un
problème de fond en ce moment c'est les
deux pays faibles de l'Union européenne
et d'un point de vue économique
effectivement les politiques et
les deux manques un petit peu de courage
oui il faut se rappeler que la une des
particularités de la personnalité
politique des R6 c'est que c'est un des
premiers politiciens de gauche qui a
utilisé justement la rhétorique de la
rotation et donc du changement politique
et c'est comme ça qu'il a obtenu le
contrôle du parti et qui après ensuite
voilà il est arrivé au pouvoir dernière
question rapidement la vie de Carretta
est-ce que vous pensez que ce front
Hollande ma théorenzi peut faire plier
Angela Merkel sur la question de la
rigueur budgétaire ou pas non non
a une dette publique qui va arriver à
140% probablement la France une centaine
une centaine
milliards d'euros de dettes voilà ça
fait
quelque chose comme en totale les deux
pays ça fait
5000 milliards d'euros
et pas de croissance économique à la fin
le qui gouverne l'Europe c'est les pays
avec une bonne croissance et peu de
dettes bon bah écoutez on terminera ce
débat là-dessus merci d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous expliciter un petit peu
les enjeux de ces réformes à l'italienne
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
avec donc Katia guilder à Bruxelles
d'ici là bonne suite de programme sur la
Chaîne Parlementaire Ciao